previously on TV sins no not down chat
[Music]
don't worry about cherry Jesus that door
open hella fast how many broken noses of
these doors caused and how many people
have been sent to the hospital while in
this hospital it'll stain if it gets on
your clothes and it'll send you into a
murderous rage if it gets in your eyes
or mouth seems like this hospital would
be doing everything it could to make
sure Jerry couldn't projectile vomit
that stuff on anybody or at the very
least make sure anyone nearby was
protected from him hello I'm dr.
glipglop if Jerry is affected by the
same mutant bacteria why didn't he get
sent into a murderous rage and maybe
Rick did something to Jerry where he
didn't have to kill him but why didn't
he do the same for the doctor is it
because I Larry what are you doing a
sequel I don't understand yeah I mean
either we pretty much nailed this the
first time acknowledging your premise is
likely not going to be very good so you
can lower people's expectations and
people can forget about the usual high
quality of your work Lee [ __ ] out that L
is fully up in there and I hope for her
sake these wooden letters have been sand
papered smooth splinters in your
sensitive bits can ruin a good wood in
the ass moment you know also you're
calling this one interdimensional cable
too even though the first one was called
rixty minutes you got some Rambo 3 in my
Rick and Morty guys not cool so every
single one of these shows will be random
and stupid in the hope of generating
roughly the same number of laughs as the
last time they did this but they went
with random ER and stupider for this one
I hope that when you told your friends
about Rick and Morty this wasn't the
first episode you showed them I'm
looking through your eyeholes boners
confused also we're about to find out
that these eye holes are a breakfast
cereal that puts their cereal on their
faces and has weird foreplay like this
or is this the species where ions come
from this is an improvisational pretzel
you're guiding me through is that rope
made of metal or is the skylight glass
really thick how did that break the
glass right after this Rick will say
that this guy actually beats you up if
you possess eye holes so I have a lot of
questions first the company making eye
holes is advertising this why would they
hire this guy as their mascot you know
the one who beats the out of you for
eating them second how does the eye hole
man know that you have aisles I mean
this guy came in a helicopter we tried
to have been in flight before this
couple even revealed their eye holes
third and more importantly you can buy
these at IKEA and why does this place
have stores earth hats
is it a comment on their ubiquity shrimp
Lee pitbulls life can be saved if we
replace his heart
with your human penis after the scenario
was revealed a writer for house woke up
in a cold sweat and yelled why didn't we
think of that the entire culture is
built around their penises and to say
this but I'll remove a sin just because
listening to him talk matter-of-factly
about jokes is hilarious but also while
I'm listening to something hilarious
look at those fly wings how are they on
the outside of the lab jacket and tell
shrimp Lee pebbles that when the galaxy
came calling Jerry Smith from Earth
didn't flinch he's right there Jer
pretty sure he just told it Beth and
summer are cruising their smartphones
from an intergalactic hospital and I'm
wondering how any of that works does the
alien hospital have Wi-Fi that connects
to different planet technology are there
satellites that transmit all the way
back to earth all summer texts with a
face like war from Star Trek that was
getting coffee how did she get there it
is it's the same woman infinite channels
infinite possibilities but sure why not
have something happened to her on TV
immediately after Morty noticed her
[Music]
seems the main problem this world is
having is that there are only eight Jan
Michael Vincent's and sixteen quadrants
the Jan Michael Vincent Factory wouldn't
send to Jan Michael Vincent's to one
quadrant I'm clearly sending a fake
movie and not Rick and Morty here but am
I gonna put this in the show or somebody
steal stuff must be a sham because that
camera didn't follow steely through the
door panned over through this huge
opening on the left side of this guy's
office so either this is a studio or
steal II went through an unnecessary
door all right okay now we're in the
quiet safe room where none of the people
whose stuff I stole can get to us yeah
but you literally stole a person you
stole from so where did you put that guy
is he tied up somewhere in your house
what was the point of stealing him we
got a bag of bhavish that's eight crap
balls first off you literally stole
items that people from Earth would
recognize from a place with nothing
alien to us whatsoever how do you
suddenly have alien items sold for alien
prices secondly I'm looking at your safe
room and you have nothing alien at all
on your shelves this whole scene seems
to be setting up the Columbus sketch for
later
get that Orthodox out of Oh
audience Killam Sikkim demons this is so
casually insane I've gotta remove acid
why does the doctor have a framed
picture of the anatomy of a human penis
does the image change based on whatever
he's researching or is he just obsessed
with all things I don't want to be that
girl but maybe there would be less
conflict if they didn't shoot their
shows at the same time summer you have
no idea how much money that must save
production what though two shows being
shot side by side with conflicting
lining and audio seems like an absolute
nightmare waste of resources
this guy has four slides that simply say
personal space the other five slides at
the very least say what you're supposed
to do with his personal space which is
to stay away from it I know this might
be the point but I find it hard to
believe any dimension finds this
entertaining also this alien in the
background is loving this countdown of
personal space slides and their
enthusiasm is infectious but it took
them seven slides to start getting into
it which I'm guessing is how long it
took the animators to get into it if
they measure the size of this alien
splatter on the wall then why is there a
need for judges enough to pay for a
brand new state-of-the-art synthetic
heart that will be even better than mr.
Smith's pathetic penis a story B story I
don't know what it is it's even more
pointless than the interdimensional
cable shows oh wait a second is that
Medea in a duck dynasty show I can't
decide if I want to remove a soon damn
how far down the chalkboard was this
premise when you brainstormed this
episode I'm a good person with a plan to
what exactly stick your penis in the
open cavity of a patient during surgery
how is this proving Jerry is a good
person I know he's an idiot but is he
this much of an idiot this is my
butthole ice cream parlor goddamn show
so now you're resorting to humor and
semi stealing from Nathan for you
episode where he convinced an ice cream
parlor to sell a poo flavor you were
shot like 50 times 67 thankfully you're
in a super sophisticated alien hospital
so it was basically like getting a
splinter removed but replacing a penis
like structure for shrim bleep pit bulls
was too difficult for this hospital you
can't make people like you you just have
to wait for hating you to bore them
cinemasins long-term strategy somehow
finds its way into a Rick and Morty
episode I mean seriously how do I holes
make any money and this [ __ ] traveled
from
other dimension to stop Jerry from
eating them penis penis penis penis
penis with your human pee ball entire
culture is built around their penises or
such and such for a pee balls would give
you people's take my penis balls these
guys they want to completely remove my
penis his penis will be your place you
want to keep your penis I prefer to keep
my penis use your penis balls just rub
my penis trying to weasel out of his
penis donation mr. Smith's pathetic
penis all of us you cut off my penis if
I were you I get a second opinion
please excuse his lack of decorum this
enthusiasm outweighs his discretion
that's right [ __ ] take my penis now
let's look at all the stuff we got in
this luxurious cream these little balls
of pigment when you blend it on the
balls burst onto your face and you get
that beautiful healthy fresh dose of
color every single time I forgot to
mention that yeah you apparently didn't
put one of the new cover sheets on your
TPS reports seconds anybody actually
have chest tubes I'm trying to set up
this saline drip and I can't get this
thing to stop beeping any
and get a shot